about the early Rogan days it's cool
that Rogan like teed you up for the
machine story yeah yes the early days
that you were doing Rogan what is that
like like the first time you do it do
you think it's anything dude oh no oh
it's not how early were you yeah walk us
through the whole thing what was the Pod
like what it looked like Etc so [__]
cool yeah you'd go to his house he'd
meet you at the front door kids running
around wife dogs
and and well the first time I I was a
fan of the show so he invited me to do
the show uh I I can't tell you how early
it was it was early enough that no one
it wasn't like huge yet right he was
still he was selling uh flashlights on
it yeah
flashlights that the specifics just the
only ones just flashlights because Aubry
Marcus right is I think his dad ran sex
stores right and says
[Laughter]
who loves you so much
[Music]
[Laughter]
those aren't even Hot Lights yeah what's
gonna happen if they pop dude I'm just
gonna make noise
what is that that little screen okay it
smells so much better
you being serious right now tears
let's just have let's just drink Bros
this will calm your nerves here I'll
drink with you I'll take yours oh gosh
here cheers the the clown has been
removed from the room let's have let's
have a let's have a tears [__] real
oh
me on here we gave you like pro-russia
memorabilia [__] I would suck
gluten's [__] right now
to [__] never have that happen again
I'm shaking I'm like shaking hold your
hands
I know they're in here like I know that
it can happen again that was Dove okay
[Laughter]
is it because the condom broke that one
time I don't know oh no it's way before
that I got it as a kid
what happened I don't know did you watch
it yeah nope oh no I never watched that
[__] movie I would never watch that
[__] movie
hey just do me a favor for real promise
me he's not coming back
sweating
and why don't you like clown yeah you
can't trust them
did you know about this uh I tried to
stop it
thank you
so for my birthday for my from um first
of all Tom needs credit for this I don't
want to act like we did it alone Tom
deserves credit for this oh that's so
cool yeah
remember when I said I let him [__] me
over yeah well you were right we waited
for you to say that on camera lucky
you're lucky I love you more than you
love me Tom
um now we do have one more thing that we
have to tell you it's just one more
thing uh what you've been drinking is a
lie
is it not I'm just [__] non-alcoholic
beer
well yeah but damn I thought we could
trick you into thinking it got spiked
but yeah we spiked it with not alcohol
we unspike we on spiked it so I've just
been gaining calories
oh wait now you care about calories
burned Jesus [__]
Jesus buddy you think I started drinking
for you
crazy don't you not get into like your
Heaven if you drink
your family
around your neck and light you on fire
or something but I don't know
I'm [__] I am off I am off I am and
that's why he brought in a real [__]
drink oh you [__] I'm sitting
here just gaining calories going why
isn't it how bad is my drinking that I
can't I mean stop acting like you're
health conscious bird no he wants to go
Trump [__] healthy as [__] right now
I want steroids are you on the [__]
juice kill my arm
yeah yeah it's awesome really how you
feel [__] amazing does it allow you
to smell things that don't exist no no
but hang on you did not smell I smelt it
the second she walked in the room I
smelled them well you also saw them no I
know but the smell is what bothers me
the smell the touching and their
unpredictability you can they're never
as soon as you do that as soon as you
inflate that thing then all of a sudden
it has the it has the possibility to
explode like a drunk alcoholic father
again never get in there for my 49th
birthday Rosebud um Baker I was on tour
with us and she thought it would be a
good idea these idiots thought it'd be a
good idea to fill my bet my bunk with
balloons to surprise me she didn't know
you were afraid she didn't know what I
was afraid of them and uh and the
[__] I came in and I [__] melted
down and this is my tour bus and it was
my bunk oh my bunk dude I've had this
happen so many times on my 40th birthday
I was in Australia and the board of
Tourism wanted to surprise me so they
put uh my they filled my entire room
with balloons my entire [__] room and
so I I was like I and I couldn't I had
nowhere to put them because it's in a
hotel room so and now I'm gonna come
home drunk and I'm in my rooms full of
balloons and I'm [__] melting down
and my wife said I call my wife and I go
I need to um
I was like I don't know what to do and
she goes just have another drink and
pass out you'll be fine just don't put
them on the roof they'll be fine in your
bedroom I couldn't and so I and then
middle of the night the helium on all of
them died at the exact same time and in
the middle of the night every bloom in
the room landed on me in the bed oh I
[__] lost it I lost it I lost it so
[__] bad
[__]
[Laughter]
but it's okay you're safe now you're
safe
never safe from balloons and clowns I
will never do the show ever again I will
never ever step foot in the studio it's
so nice knowing you guys
okay
check out my special Razzle Dazzle
that was the name of the clown actually
my movie The Machine it's coming out
Memorial Day weekend it's amazing it's
amazing
it's amazing how like uh how it really
hit me I don't know if you saw it like
I'm yeah right now I'm just starting to
relax just a titch but first of all
how much is a titch
not much
now Bert I know the balloons are in this
fight I have to walk past them oh no we
put them I've never been allowed to have
balloons no way so their birthdays they
never had a clown or a balloon or
anything hold on no one's getting a
[__] clown that's the dumbest [__]
yeah have you ever had a clown no no
actually it's fire dude my my friends
had clowns out there your parents didn't
bring a clown in it's like the whitest
thing in the world no it's my friend's
parents but yeah the clown was fire he
rubbed his [__] leg on a coloring
book opened it up and Pages were blank
crazy
how do you feel about magic I don't mind
magic
I like magic
you can't you can trust magic but not
clowns yeah I don't know dude you know
what's funny is Tom texted me he goes uh
hey you should do the balloon clown
thing later in the episode because he's
gonna get real jittery and I just sent
back hahaha thinking that he was just
busting balls but like it is changed you
emotionally yeah it's [__] great who
do you hate more us or Ari yeah would
you have rather we thought we were doing
a nice thing unspiking the drink yeah
unspike your drinks really yeah
so funny I didn't even look at the cans
I was drinking
alcatonya she hid all the non-alcoholic
beers behind the Stellas it was good
that was good yeah I probably I'm not
even [__] around I'm not even [__]
around
I trust Ari more than I trust you guys
because I can't promise that you'll
never do something like that again like
I know Ari pulled me aside one time and
he goes you have to know I'll never drug
you again and I went I do believe that
oh
I don't I just don't trust you like what
do you think that we would do like for
example at the Forest Hill show you
don't think we would hire like a hundred
clowns to sit for a row or anything
right
oh I'll toss them I'll toss them on the
street Daniel Tosh right there oh
[__] Daniel toss them listen they're
all gonna get in the same car and drive
away
this will be the biggest clip you I've
ever had of me ever I'm being serious
because I there's no I can't I'm not
turning anything on right now I'm being
100 me this is 100 me when my wife sees
this my wife's gonna go oh [__] they
didn't do that did they [__]
well Tom did it we had nothing to do
with it really hey hey hey Schultz why
do you and Burt not talk to each other
anymore well we brought seven balloons
in during the episode it wasn't seven
that wasn't seven how many what does it
smell like I'm being dead serious you
guys didn't smell it a dozen the second
oh man the smell is what [__] got me
the clown I mean we'll probably do more
the balloons that touch you or the
balloons uh
uh probably probably the balloons
so the balloons is like an allergy for
you no no it's just I don't know what it
is I don't know what it is you can't
trust them you ever seen a blimp it's
yeah he talks
you can't trust him you're good with
blimps yeah this all sounds like
euphemisms for Jewish people but you
actually mean the thing
you can't trust clowns dude no you can't
no just clowns are meant it just doesn't
make any sense where someone would do
that to themselves
and they forgoti's Dad I think is a
clown oh yeah he is yeah and magicians
and I almost couldn't become friends
with him with Nate because I couldn't
understand
how he could have that in his family and
I'm not even [__] right he was made
from clown sperm you couldn't understand
how Nate could have it in his family but
he would yeah I couldn't get it I love
Nate and I'm when I met Nate it was like
the first thing I go you guys like a
clown right and he goes yeah and he was
really proud of me he's really proud of
his dad and his dad actually is
apparently I'll never see it but an
amazing performer he opens he opens
grenade sometimes for him but I just
couldn't I couldn't wrap my head around
it
I watched I I went home and the chick
she was going to be seven or she was
going to be six my wife is seven the
number of girl you were gonna have sex
with this girl you allude to [__]
kids without even trying yeah it's crazy
I start the sentence over yeah let's do
it again what would have been the
seventh woman I've ever had sex yeah God
damn it yeah
because before you just
we're not friends
[Music]
definitely not doing [__] Logan
Paul's podcast now
but what's his name not Logan Paul the
other one Jared Paul Jake Paul so Logan
Paul Logan Paul Logan Paul yeah I'm
definitely not doing that [__]
podcasts because this is the harambe
generation yeah this is the wrong Bay
generation I'm gonna do his [__]
thing and he's gonna have a clown come
in yeah because this action this is all
everyone's a [__]
went home with the chick one time yeah
and she was beautiful living in Venice
she and she said you know can I show you
um what I do this is a bizarre story
and uh she put in clown porn
she was a she shot a documentary on
cloud porn and I'm not even joking uh
Vince Vaughn was in it like he was like
he was like there's an extra in the back
she was friends with Vince Vaughn and
these two clowns were like and I
literally I was like what the [__] I
gotta get up and he was Vince was with
my buddy Gary R back and I go is that
Gary our back she goes she goes yeah you
know carry our back here she said I've
been fun and then I saw the clowns and I
was like ah and I just walked out I was
like I have to leave right now
why would they ruin sex like that you
know why did she want to show you I have
no [__] clue you guys went home to
have sex and then as like a little like
foreplay can I show you something and
then she put in clown porn hey buddy you
okay take a deep breath I'm not we're
not bringing the balloons back I promise
you there's no more there's no more
clowns deep breath in through the nose
out through the mouth you know what I
mean Indian things
you got this man you can conquer
anything bro are you interested in
getting over it like through therapy
nope not even nope like like immersion
therapy nothing you're just cool just
living your life never been around a
balloon I don't need to be around don't
don't don't don't don't do don't I'm not
doing it I just saw you lick your bottom
weapon that was you know I did that
because you were laughing at me thinking
I already made a promise to him that
there's no more clowns and no more
balloons yeah we're making another drink
actual drink we'll bring you an actual
drink Pete
the drink
we need another drink Pete you don't
have a show tonight do you because I'm
worried you're not gonna be able to oh
you're gonna produce a special
[Laughter]
shout out to Shane Torres Torres
shooting is special I can't believe I
can't turn it around I'm shut down I'm
like shut down but this is beautiful how
often do people get this version of Bert
Kreischer uh never if you're on an
airplane with me you'll get it oh are
you afraid I'm terrified flying oh
that's what you did oh that's why you do
the tour bus ah